mark Holmes our fashion stylist the  thing that I like most or that I take  the most from British fashion is  probably the tailoring aspect when I  think of American fashion a story that  comes to mind is the workwear story  denim and the 50s and the 40's we've got  Luke here and I'm very well-tailored  suit right down to two inch have no  break then I paired it down with a denim  shirt here to give it sort of an  American twist on the tailoring element  not to mention we got a nice rugged boot  with this look here you can really wear  it anywhere it's got formal elements  it's got rugged comfortable elements I  think something really special happens  when you blend those two worlds together  that's the way we progress forward with  everything right taking one idea from  one spot and one idea from another  putting together and something new is  formed I like that  just like the mcallen double cast  combining oak from two sides of the  world to create a beautiful whiskey